[موسيقى]
اول الاشهر الحرم شهر ذا القعده والاشهر
الحرم اربعه ثلاثه
متواليه ذا القعده وذا الحجه هو محرم
وواحد منفرد عنها وهي الاشهر التي يحرم
فيها القتال ايا كان وشهر ذا القعده هو
شهر الحادي عشر من شهور السنه الهجريه وهي
سنه قمريه تعتمد على رؤيه الهلال في
شهورها وسمي بهذا لقعود الناس فيه عن
القتال ليش حتى يامن الحديث الى الوصول
الى المشاعر المقدسه لاداء مناسك الحج في
كل امن وامان من السراق وقطاع الطرق يا
سارق الانفاسي كيف عبثت بي وانا الكتوم
الحاذق المتحذر يا شاغل العينين كيف
سلبتني ووقعت في محضوري ما اتحذروا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر ذا القعده لهذه السنه في اوله ينتصف
موسم الكنه وهو موسم الحر الفعلي النهاري
وفي نهايته يبدا نزول الامطار الخريفيه
على اليمن وسلطنه عمان وجنوب السعوديه وفي
منتصفه ينتهي موسم الامطار الطبيعيه على
جل المناطق ويتزامن ذلك مع دخول موسم
اتويبع وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون
اتويبع راعي بروكن ومخايل ومذكر وادي
بتويبع
ساير
[موسيقى]